so when he says it's a huge blow Elon
Musk says this wouldn't what is that
what are the consequences of that for
SpaceX well of course anytime you have a
serious mishap like this it's going to
be a setback you know they lost the
rocket they lost spacecraft and so what
that means is they're going to be
delayed now before they can even plan
the next launch they've got to figure
out the root cause of this problem and
make sure it's not a generic problem in
their fleet and then make the
corrections necessary do the testing to
certify before they can fly so the
bottom line is they've been set back in
both time and dollars but you know it's
not a fatal it's not a fatal set back by
any means Leroy if you are currently on
the International Space Station would
this give you any concern well of course
anytime you lose a resupply ship it is
going to be a concern fortunately there
are enough supplies of critical items
like oxygen water and food to keep the
crew going for several more months just
a couple days ago a Russian resupply
ship successfully docked so no no undue
amount of concern for the crew on board
just a little head scratching that you
know three supply ships were lost in a
row but unrelated you know we had
different different sources for the
supply ships is there you know it via
LAN said that you know it's gonna take a
long time or take a while at least to
figure out what happened is there any
finding that could deal a fatal blow to
the program at all well if they had a
succession of failures if they started
losing several launches that would you
know and and people lost confidence in
them in that case I think that would be
pretty serious I don't think that's
gonna happen you know Elon Musk on
SpaceX are gonna have a lot of help from
NASA who have who has a lot of
experience in these kind of mishap
investigations so I'm confident that
they'll find the root cause and then fix
the fix the issue I just quickly Leah I
mean Elon has always said he builds
Rockets cheaper than those in Russia is
any of this have to do with cost do you
think no I don't think so this is a
development program I mean SpaceX Falcon
9 is a very new rocket they did have 18
successful flights before this one and
so they've actually got a very good
track record for a new rocket but you
know they've had anomalies before I
valve's of stuck things have happened
and they've learned from those and
fortunately none of those had had a
resulted in a loss of a vehicle